uh this is a long ass video oh I edited
it down oh but to be fair to the woman
who created this video uh she was very
thoughtful about a lot of the stuff that
she said and there were some good points
that she made and so if you want you go
check out her video and see which parts
you guys agree with or don't agree with
don't let us inform you so the link is
below so you can go watch it without our
input yet but I'll play portions and I
thought were interesting that I want to
talk about with preach and then we'll
just kind of go from there lonely single
men are on the rise due to higher dating
standards
oh my God it was like a mating call or
something but anyway saw this and
immediately looked it up because I was
like is this real maybe this isn't real
come to find out or as we say in Wolff
these articles were published literally
like a day or two
before so turns out this is actually
true although as always there's more to
the story but this is all research from
the Pew Research Center I think a place
that most people find trustworthy and
when I was looking at the research
article I didn't expect it to be as long
as it was because it was honestly very
broad strokes but it was mostly talking
about how yeah just statistically you're
just really worse off if you're
unpartnered especially if you are an
unpartnered male not just unpartnered
people but unpartnered straight men and
why they are unpartnered and the effects
it'll have on their health mental
physical well-being all of that and how
and speaking in binaries how for women
it's actually like healthier apparently
or you know I'm not to have a
a husband or children weighing them down
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding
so if you even know like I don't know
maybe a bit about feminism you've
probably heard the saying a woman
without a man is like a fish without a
bicycle fish don't need bicycles just
like women don't need men in this time
period especially and not that this is
the first time it's ever happened but
time when we started realizing oh what
do I really need a guy for besides
if I like to have sex and it's not to
say that the dudes didn't deserve the
kind of energy we were bringing because
I'm gonna get to it as I mentioned from
the Pew research they were pointing out
how men that are unpartnered there's
just there's just diminishing of your
quality of life I guess overall and for
women it seems to be the opposite in
contrast women benefit far more from
being alone according to Professor Paul
Dolan a happiness expert and professor
of Behavioral Science at the London
School of Economics the quote healthiest
and happiest population subgroup are
women who never married or had children
article that she's quoting to support
the idea that women are better off by
themselves yeah is by some scientists
named Paul Dolan okay and he reads this
public available data and he comes to
the conclusion and I quote if you're a
man you should probably get married if
you're a woman don't bother and when you
hear it it sounds like it rings true so
you assume it is let me tell you I wish
homegirl would have just done another
Google search uh because this guy's been
debunked already so it's a Vox article
that was great and basically this Vox
writer let me just make sure I get her
name right yeah Kelsey Piper and she got
an article that says a new book says
married women are miserable don't
believe it okay shout outs to you lady
and basically she goes on to debunk the
fact that this guy when he was quoting
the statistics did so incorrectly
um and he had to retract afterwards what
he said in his book because he admits
that he quoted this stuff incorrectly I
hear this all the time I could do bad
all myself and you hear these studies
and we're like women are happier well
it's not true it's not true it's not
true gray Kimbrough he was an economist
at the American University of public
affairs who uses a server that who uses
the survey data that this Paul Dolan
used
and basically what this guy realized he
said I'm no happiness expert and don't
have strong ideological feelings about
whether or not everyone should be
getting married or not but I have done a
ton of research with the American time
use survey which he's used to base his
statements and the claims felt weird to
me first off there's a statement that
when married woman spouse is not in the
room she's [ __ ] miserable
I know that this information isn't
included so I reached out to him he has
since retracted this statement and will
correct it in his book the citation the
second paragraph crucially does not say
that there are no benefits to women
marrying only that there are not as
large as benefits to men meaning and
when I talk oftentimes about this topic
the way that men and women have to
bridge this Gap because we only have
each other people like why should I
women are thriving by themselves and I'm
like no you're not this is just made of
[ __ ] like stop saying this stuff
because you're going off faulty
information and you're building your
whole [ __ ] life for you you're going
into these relationships thinking like
oh shit's gonna be sweet on the other
side when it's not and you're doing it
based off information that's untrue
people are selling you this stuff
because it appeals to you right I can
understand someone tells you you don't
need men you can live forever by
yourself you want to listen to that
person because it's empowering the same
way red pill people say a bunch of that
stuff to these young men and it's
empowering to them [ __ ] these [ __ ]
you just get this money you're gonna
like that's that's that side this is the
other side of the delusion where it's
just like we don't need others we don't
need these it's not true
every statistical number shows that
you're going to do worse off if you're
by yourself the only difference is women
do slightly worse so why are you
celebrating that this is akin to two
people [ __ ] drowning and one looking
at the other and be like well you're
drowning faster [ __ ] you all gonna die
why are you concerned about the fact
that he's drowning a little bit faster
that's gonna be you soon too we're so
like men versus women we don't realize I
say this all the time it's not about
women are wrong or men are wrong or
whatever the [ __ ] it is yo [ __ ] we
only got each other
well if men are not gonna chase tough
they're the only men you have
you gonna go to a different planet I
ain't never [ __ ] you getting some
alien dick I don't know about if women
are gonna be like this [ __ ] where you
gonna get your ladies like do you guys
not realize there's only these two
genders
hold up 75 whoa what'd you get what I'm
trying to say there's only these two
Sexes right thank you we only have each
other
so when I hear this narrative constantly
being pretty I'm like first off it's
mostly like young delusional women who
are saying this stuff yeah okay
and secondly
this is like
go ask the old people who buy themselves
go ask them
why do you think remarriage always
happens in the latter years
how many times do old people get
remarried yeah all the time yeah
because they understand that that alone
[ __ ] is [ __ ] up and I'm not even like
not being old just there alone in your
apartment you just yo it's [ __ ] up you
could deny it and be like no no I'm good
I'm good I'm good I'm good until the
[ __ ] gets lonely everybody everybody
without everybody that I've seen that
was talking about I'm good alone I'm
good alone I'm good alone
sexual and I was a woman eventually
they're like yeah but it'd be nice
eventually they're like yeah but it'd be
nice but I'm good I'm good I'm good you
repeat that [ __ ] so much that I'm really
starting to think are you trying to
convince yourself
because I heard you the first 54 times
that you said it but now you're like I
want this I want this I'm good I'm good
I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm
good I'm good I'm good I'm good Ah
that's why I'm good I'm really good I'm
good I'm good and then the loneliness
come it sucks it sucks
sucks for a man too by the way I don't
know about you guys but wallets have
always been an issue for me that's where
today's sponsor extra comes into play
what I love about this wallet the design
the fact that it's efficient uh I stick
all the cards that I need inside here
and then if at any point I want to pull
them out I only need to sift through my
thing I just like this poop and then I
know which card it is I just pull out
the car real Sleek push it back in boom
simple and it doesn't fall out as you
can see right here doesn't matter how
much I shake honestly it feels like one
of them Batman toys is that cool extra
also has some cool accessories that
involve using an app on your phone you
can activate this tracker and the
tracker stays with it so when you're
traveling this could be a godsend and
there's many times this kind of
Technology would have saved my ass so
amazing design amazing functionality at
amazing prices and what's more if you
follow the link in the description below
right now they got a good old Christmas
sale going so you can get up to 40 off
that's right you can save some money you
feel me get yourself one of these and
treat yourself there's no reason why I
need to go with these big bulky wallets
or maybe if it's not for you you know I
mean there's a special man you know in
your life ladies if you guys are
thinking of what to get your man you
know I mean for this holiday season
this is it every dude I've shown it to
so far is like I gotta get me one of
those so don't hesitate guys use a link
in the description below and get
yourself one too yeah and it's important
because you know sometimes these video
essays on YouTube do like these video
think pieces that make it seem like
everything's so well researched and
thought out and like it's not a lot of
these people are operating off faulty
information they read a single book and
they're like I understand feminism I got
the truth I just don't buy it and I'm
not saying This Woman's intention lies
not that is that oftentimes even I have
this bias I imagine is that when you
have information that confirms the truth
that's convenient to you or aligns with
your world view you just run with it
yeah just be careful whether it's us
whether it's her whether it's anybody
else on YouTube understand just because
they say this and they cite something
you have to look beyond the citation and
be like well where did this study
actually come from what do they actually
what did they actually did they read the
study properly your main point which is
that women are better off not getting
married it's just untrue your life
expectancy drops the amount of money
that you rate drops your happiness
levels drop according to all the metrics
that we have out there to report that
these things are lower for unpartnered
people the way to the world works
unfortunately the way the world works
you have to be too yup groceries having
a roof over your hand kids raising kids
it's better with two [ __ ] it's
just like that but hey also friends
sound great as an idea when you're young
until as you get older people either
have kids they have their own families
they move out of state to go live with
other people it's like this idea like
you're gonna always hold your friend
group and you guys are always going to
be close everything's gonna be great
he's not nearly as true as you get older
or an age those phase ships start to
fade [ __ ] change absolutely people got
lives [ __ ] change people start to get
kids people so I tell you don't handle
their business that person was free to
help you out when that person was free
to help you out but check this how many
times you hear girls complain oh all my
[ __ ] friends are getting married yep
yep how many times did you do that and
why do they complain about that because
they ain't got nobody to chill they
ain't got nobody to be around you ain't
got nobody it starts to feel very
[ __ ] lonely you know it's always
funny those women who were like I could
do bad all the last time I could do bad
online stuff that they find a man what
they like
and then I was like you back then and I
hear my sisters I hear them I hear my
sister I could do this but when you say
the love of your life it's just so late
you go back home
you just go back home and he's dead
foreign
the minute you find that special someone
and then you but before you're like nah
I'm a bad [ __ ] I'm a bad [ __ ] I'm a
bad [ __ ] I'm a bad [ __ ]
you're not Beyonce and even when Beyonce
wrote single ladies and just saying that
[ __ ] she was with Jay-Z [ __ ]
she was with Jay-Z
they're all these dating apps coming out
as well and with dating apps it's just
numbers and Screen just tons and tons
and tons of people you just it's kind of
like a little cyber dating Buffet you
just click through left right left right
people almost stop being people and are
just the pictures and the brief bit that
you might gather from them we need to be
able to be honest with ourselves about
how our feelings are hurt that a lot of
the dudes we know it's not just men you
date dads Brothers uncles cousins best
friends gay or straight queer whatever
if you're socialized as a boy that's
socialization ends up having a lot more
to do with how in control can you be how
dominant can you be how much of a quote
man can you be then
how are you as a person
um how do you feel uh
uh who are you who are you discovering
yourself to be how do you choose to
express yourself
um
let's talk
you know it's always interesting the way
people try to define the male experience
and how
not accurate like I think when women
describe the male experience I'm like
what oh my God you think you know but
you know what it makes me think of it's
like when dudes talk about ladies on a
lot of these podcasts they'd be like
these [ __ ] [ __ ] on Instagram just
dming thousands of men things
spreading the PO y forever like they
always go to this caricature that's it
so extreme yeah and then these ladies do
the same thing where she's like these
guys are emotionally stunted and unable
to speak about their feelings ever and
they just want to be in control and
dominated meanwhile I'm just playing
[ __ ] Smash Bros with my [ __ ] just
having a good time laughing about [ __ ]
like chill it's not that deep hey [ __ ]
who gonna be dominant
the way women Define male spaces they
think like we're all just like Trump
just [ __ ] so I grabbed it by the
[ __ ] right you know I was like what you
guys have no idea what male spaces look
like the more I hear women talk about it
the more I recognize it yeah I was like
oh okay you don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ]
it's fine you don't that's the second
thing how are you as a person [ __ ]
don't want to be around that energy not
a single one if a girl ever keep me with
that kind of like you can leave now
so what are you feeling on the inside oh
my God doesn't say so I'm just training
so no they don't say that what
what you thinking oh my God
I [ __ ] hit you right I hit you with
that [ __ ] yeah I hit you with that [ __ ]
right GSD like I hit you with that [ __ ]
yeah and we have this rise that we see
of this manosphere and sells all this
sort of stuff retaliating against this
Independence you know because you see
the pendulums that that's an extreme
reaction but what can we learn from that
and what I think we can learn from that
is that it's a lot deeper than just
thinking men are trash in my opinion my
opinion speaking a frustration into the
world
about how difficult it is to not only
connect with men understand men Vibe
with men but even tolerate them at times
like that's wild to think about you have
us doing all manner of emotional labor
once all of us started realizing we
could do you know bad all by ourselves
and really we're committed to that
and saw the fruits of our labor and all
that stuff no matter how capitalist pink
washed it was in my opinion my opinion
brought about this even bigger Chasm
because not only were men then already
kind of in that camp of not really being
emotionally intelligent or being
required to be sex economics the man
works and women hold power as sex and
give it to men depending on how much
money that like that weird messed up
mentality of all men have to offer is
what's on the outside the physical you
know what kills me women always talk
about how emotionally intelligent they
are
and I think they think that just because
they talk about their emotions they're
more emotionally intelligent
but my experience has generally been
that women barely can see their own
behavior or their own shortcomings
emotionally which is why we get therapy
and which is why the reason why we don't
talk off the time because the way
sometimes you guys react is messed up
you know sometimes we don't talk about
[ __ ] because
your real reaction is gonna be [ __ ] up
you assume a lot of [ __ ]
because you assume that you're
emotionally more stable and intelligent
so if I come up with some [ __ ] the
backlash is going to be real
yeah you think I want to deal with a
backlash as a man I shut the [ __ ] up
it's easier for me but women sometimes
talk themselves into circles about
emotions and they think they're being so
profound but they're just talking into
the air and saying a lot of nothing and
then sometimes your point is like you
don't realize that you're physically
do it what it's like you've got all this
time to dissect every single thought I
have but you don't even notice that you
be hitting people all the time when you
get frustrated
you got all this outward time to be like
this this did you know that half of all
physical altercations when it comes to
marital and relationship related stuff
is initiated by women but if you ask 95
of women if they ever done something
like nah most women I know and this is
just of course completely anecdotal love
talking about emotions but it doesn't
mean that they have a deep understanding
of them it doesn't mean that they're
mostly mature enough to really
understand the whole gravitas everything
now I will credit women that think
they're much more open about these
things
but being open is not enough there's a
lot of introspection that has to happen
beyond that and when I hear ladies talk
they sound like they're the masters of
emotion no no you're the masters of
talking about them doesn't mean you've
mastered them that's why if you look at
the big pie personality traits women
hate rate way higher when it comes to
neuroticism
you guys will display everything don't
mean you need to have a good control or
a handle over them or a deep
understanding of them you just like
talking about them
and it's really when it's and you're
good at talking about it when it happens
to you even when you hear women talk
about the exes I swear on my mother's
life every woman has been in a
relationship with a narcissist Every
Woman even
their friend is a narcissist
they got some kind of mental health
disorder every single one of them and
they're not even being hyperbolic
they're serious I have one time she
dated three narcissist
that the common denominator no no you
understand the odds of that possibility
yo that's [ __ ] up like [ __ ] sign up
for the lottery because you gonna win
apparently yeah well those odds yeah
absolutely you need three narcissists in
a row in a row
it's like I don't know what's wrong with
me I just attract them Jesus really are
you sure lady come on bro
they do this all this outward projection
of like mental health stuff and
analyzing emotions and he gaslit me and
there was manipulation involved and all
this other stuff and you ask them like
when have you engaged that or never
you've never manipulated a man no
all I'm trying to say is I could look at
my own past dating behavior and
acknowledge there have been times I've
been manipulative there's been times
I've Maybe
misrepresented facts or whatever it
might be lied go ahead but you ask them
like yo when it comes to your own
behavior do you see it and a lot of them
be like whoa and you ask them are you a
master of emotions these things they got
a PhD in [ __ ] feelings bro but and no
they just they oftentimes they feel
everything and they really think it's a
truth that is the truth I felt it that's
what happens yeah okay but let's see how
that happened I'm not gonna say what you
did for that to happen because that's
victim blaming but let's just dissect
how that happened and we came to this